en quelques heures apple va dévoiler ses
derniers joujoux avec non pas un mais
bien quatre nouveaux téléphones pour des
prêts allant 2029 à 1729 euros combien
et oui le prix de l'iphone n'a cessé de
croître depuis 2007 pour atteindre
aujourd'hui des sommets 599 euros départ
1080 en 2017 et 1400 euros en moyenne
aujourd'hui ça fait beaucoup la non de
hausse des prix qui serait due à
l'inflation à la hausse du coût de
l'énergie et à la pénurie des composants
alors malgré toutes ces nouveautés qui
propose 1400 euros pour nouvel iphone
trouvez vous ça scandaleux couleurs
chez
eux 1400 euros c'est la folie 1 c'est
vrai que là franchement c'est un truc de
fou qui vous vous êtes vous compreniez
alors autant ça me choque pas qu'on
dépense des sommes pour des produits de
luxe parce qu'on est dans le tertiaire
la ce qui me choque c'est qu'en fait
l'évolution de la société a fait
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus
travailler voir vivre sans un smartphone
aujourd'hui il ya un français sur quatre
et un iphone os qu'apple qui sont en
train de faire c'est de condamner 25%
des français a claqué un smic pour avoir
un téléphone qui m'a juste servir à
travailler à rester en contact avec les
gens apple c'est des entreprises les
plus riches du monde je pense qu'il
pourrait faire un effort lui de se gaver
sur les gens et leur faire payer
franchement un smic pour un téléphone
c'est scandaleux oui moi je suis
clairement pas d'accord parce qu'à un
moment donné ou en fait on ne force pas
acheter iphone
donc toutes les personnes qui achètent
iphone c'est qu'ils ont les moyens c'est
comme tout le luxe que tu te payes toit
ainsi donc si les personnes qui s'achète
en espérant que ça c'est qu'ils y voient
un intérêt parce qu'en fait ça réunit
énormément de deux produits que tu n'as
plus attachés que sa commission d'appel
avec ça remplace le télé ça remplace le
téléphone ça remplace la télé ça
remplace l'appareil photo ça remplace
énormément de choses donc s'il ya des
gens qui sont assez fric et comme toi
pour s'acheter plat et bah tant mieux
pour le move en otage des gens comme ça
ils ont payé un téléphone soit 0 ils ont
par téléphone saint simon raux il ya
quelques années ils les prennent en
otage il faut évoluer ils font triper
pris
25% des gens qui ont des
iphone ericsson bien entendu également
samsung
si t'es pas content tu ne peux pas c'est
pas non mais également répondre à
l'argument qui n'est bon c'est vrai que
ton argument est bon sauf que moi je
suis tombé dans le piège de l'iphone
mais je vais il ya des gens ils peuvent
pas sortir d'iphone et envoyé non parce
que quand ils sont à l'habitude d'être
en avez chaud
écoute le ski dit guillaume d'or sans la
prise d'otages je voulais rester sur mon
iphone l'iphone 5 on m'a dit non le
cinquième faut que tu nous donnes tu te
sens bien tant débarrasse parce qu'il
prend plus assez de mémoire pour les
réseaux sociaux tu peux plus pour les
mises à jour tu pues faut acheter un
autre téléphone donc j'ai acheté un
autre téléphone j'ai pris la science est
même passé combien cela c'est lui tout
le set by you say say say locales 11
400 balles et que tu donnes tu donnes me
paraît le smic ses 1300
gillot à un smic c'est trop c'est
honteux c'est à dire que c'est une
sélection par l'argent d'un téléphone
c'est à dire que c'est réservé aux plus
riches et un pont non mais moi je pense
aux ados tout ça et c'est bien sûr un
point incroyable de la population à voir
des gens riches alors cet iphone en
rêvait sûr que jamais la voix est
amplement des fous
iphone c'est un menteur maintenant quel
monde au vigile qui laisse entendre que
tout le monde a besoin de ce téléphone
je suis fait baiser par don en achetant
des os et dents par deux amicaux
précédents qui étaient amis de balle aux
1200 balle c'était le 12 400 je pense
que j'utilise 10% à peu près de la
mémoire et de tout je me ferai pas avoir
la prochaine fois qui a besoin d'un
iphone le dernier iphone tu bosses avec
1,8 très très bien tu bosses avec un
cette tâche est inquiète et robotique et
où c'est pas encore pour 400 balles amat
a perdu en d'acheter ça a bougé mais si
leur marketing fait ils rendent sa
indispensable c'est super bien faire et
c'est terminé c'est faut donc faut le
dire aux gens t'as pas besoin de cet
iphone est sacré de la vie
qui bat oui pardon non mais ça crée de
la jalousie c'est une manière qui a des
gens qui sont d'ailleurs pour l'aider
j'admets que scénique
téléphone c'est un produit quotidien
tout le monde a un téléphone c'est vrai
on en a on en a besoin
la jalousie est l'éternel tu vas avoir
des bijoux on va être jaloux de toi tu
vas mourir son bijou c'est un produit de
luxe a téléphoné
daniel mon frère moi je suis je vais
m'adresser aux gens de wattao réveiller
c'est pourquoi c'est que j'essayais de
transcrire en francs et en fait ces dix
jeunes gens qui ont connu les franchisés
moi ça fait 1 millions de centimes c'est
parce que je raconte mais c'est son jeu
gran sasso moins tendance à farinas on
l'a senti mentalement tation n'est pas
légitime c'est-à-dire que aller quand il
déjà quand il coûtait 1000 euros on
trouvait ça excessivement cher et à la
limite ne doit pas pas mais quand tu
côtoies tu vois augmenté d'année en
année et que tu vois que les
technologies d'intérieur a à peine bougé
d'un micro truc à l'intérieur donc la
rue d'auteuil non mais là a priori c'est
ce que dit en tout cas sur les forums et
les cinq années en disant quand l'iphone
12 et là ils sont 14 n'a pas une grande
différence bon ben voilà donc c'est le
sentiment d'être un pigeon est par
ailleurs effectivement les gars quand
ton d'allergie dans le truc à la mode
oui les gars veulent avoir le truc à la
bonne et moi je pense aux parents qu'ils
ne peuvent passer sa chance à la même
chose bien sûr exactement celle et chez
les ados se met à saigner pour essayer
d'offrir bien sûr téléphone qu'ils ne
peuvent pas offrir et en plus de ça en
règle générale c'est compatible médaille
pour qu'on les cons les gamins et ça et
ces travaux bénard sol est excellent à
nîmes oui bravo année des plans
[Applaudissements]
donnez vous écouter ok je peux dire un
petit mot raciste et j'ai fini j'ai vu
ce sujet mais vas-y pardon dans la
famille ben on est plutôt aisés ont un
petit peu d'argent on a de la chance
elle matois stopper pas mais deux neveux
combattants n'ont pas les derniers à
tort n'ont pas d'iphone soit arrêter de
penser qu' on voit se saigner tous pour
donner un iphone serait son enfant je
sais très bien aujourd'hui c'est que les
ados presse qu'il devienne roi mois de
décembre par elle mais par an il avait
des moyens et ben j'avais pas lu la
dernière chose à la mode de jeu c'est
une question sur la corruption au
collège et à avoir des derniers iphone
tuyaux faire racketter de sherlock
holmes assez compliqué dans un monde
idéal mais tu sais très bien qu'ils
font et tous les parents et les f1 fait
et elle semble être ensemble et bien il
y aura chômé entre une jalousie sa mort
censurant qui tient parfois oui kelly
vouliez dire quelque chose
[Rires]
vous lie to me disais quoi aux os et aux
c'est génialement saint chély bloqués à
temps mais c'est quoi je vous entend
déjà parler là au bout là bas mot
c'était benjamin c'est tous les jours et
j'aurai de voir tous les gens bourrés là
bas
et
là mais vous criez tous au scandale mais
bien sûr ça va être un carton et les
gens en face aux violations vous voulez
rendre le business éthique et moral ce
soir vous êtes quand même des grands
naïfs c'est à dire que si c'est pas
comme le disait très justement kelly je
suis d'accord avec tout ce qu'elle a dit
si c'est pas le cas ce sera le basque
les baskets c'est pas le basket ce sera
le cimetière plus embêté à soigner
société ne souhaite chérie tu souhaites
sûr c'est parce qu'en fait on est dans
une société de consommation les roues
les gens et les jeunes ne vis pas bien
sûr machin donc j'ai tout arrêté de
croire qu'on est pas obligé de l'acheter
mais ma si on n'est pas dans la liste
des sondés dans un objet nécessaire et
we have eyes et casse tout le monde mais
alors d'un smartphone et arrêter de
faire les additions à qui vous avez quoi
vous des 33 disent non vous soyez un
véhicule manteau trois drones et de sa
bonne 14e
qui va aujourd'hui nous parlons ne peut
pas travailler son smartphone avec les
magasins de 2,7 marco la juge
ne dépense pas souffert sur l'euro et
peut-être des prix plus abordables comme
500 euros comme c'était le cas il ya
encore quelques années je sais pas
pourquoi ce qu'est un magasin sur le sur
le libraire magasin devait chéri petit 2
pour l'ameublement et l'électroménager
bouchony si oui il va y avoir deux
mondes ceux qui peuvent se payer cet
iphone et ces
deux mondes
réseau
vous pouvez pas entériner un monde où
des gens
c'est vrai
c'est pas
mal je devrais pascal a dit non mais
franchement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
simple et
sortez d'aller héritera et un par là que
je vois je voudrais pas vous parler band